let's take a quick look at how to deploy
Python 3 applications to Google App
Engine I have a Python 3 application
that runs great on my local machine and
I want to deploy to App Engine all my
dependencies are listed in my
requirements text file to deploy our
code go to cloud.google.com sign in to
your google account if you haven't done
so already and then go to my console
make sure you sign up for the free trial
if you haven't done that yet now go to
select a project and create a project
give your project a name and click
create then go to the compute engine
section and make sure billing is enabled
if you don't have the Google Cloud SDK
installed on your computer
see the link in the description for how
to install it create a file called a PMO
with the following information we are
using Python 3 and unicorn to run our
server run g-cloud init to login to your
Google account now run g-cloud app
deploy to deploy your application in a
few minutes your application should be
deployed go to the URL and you can see
your application running on the cloud